bonjour Olivier Faure merci beaucoup
merci d'être invité ce matin député de
Seine-et-Marne premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste est toujours à mes
côtés Stéphane Vernet de Ouest-France
pour cette interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale on va évidemment
parler du Parti socialiste dans quelques
instants Olivier merci beaucoup d'être
venue nous réserver votre réaction à ce
qui se passe mais d'abord un mot sur la
réforme des retraites puisque le
gouvernement a présenté donc il y a sa
réforme des retraites il est inflexible
sur le report de l'âge de départ c'est
ce qu'on dit hier les ministres Emmanuel
Macron se dit lui ouvert à des
modifications dans le débat
parlementaire vous pouvez vous pensez
pouvoir l'améliorer cette réforme des
retraites
au report de l'âge légal or c'est bien
là qui est le problème central et
problème central qui est maintenant
dénoncé par tout le monde y compris vous
avez peut-être lu il y a quelques heures
celui qui a été l'auteur de la réforme
en Suède la même réforme et qui dit
surtout ne faites pas ce que j'ai fait
ça a des conséquences désastreuses et ça
appauvrit les retraités donc la réalité
c'est que tout le monde aujourd'hui est
les pieds sur les freins sauf le
gouvernement qui cherche à accélérer et
contrairement à ce que les Stanislas
Guérini la réalité c'est qu'ils ont
choisi un plfssr donc un véhicule
législatif qui permet en réalité de se
contrefoutre du débat parce qu'au bout
de 50 jours quoi qu'il arrive il procède
par ordonnance donc c'est un passage en
force caractérisé sur une réforme que
personne ne s'ajustifiait le corps vient
de le dire il y a sur quatre scénarios
possibles trois scénaris ou en fait tous
s'équilibre tranquillement sans avoir
besoin de faire quoi que ce soit et un
scénario ou effectivement il y a un
problème d'équilibre mais qui peut être
tout à fait en réalité réalisée par
d'autres moyens que le recul de l'âge
légal donc rien ne va dans ce projet et
c'est tout le problème c'est qu'on a un
gouvernement qui a une réforme
idéologique qui considère que en fait il
faut faire peser cette réforme
uniquement exclusivement sur les
salariés qui ont travaillé le plus tôt
qui sont avec les travaux les plus
pénibles les salaires les moins élevés
et l'espérance de vie la plus courte
c'est pas une question de que dit le
gouvernement là c'est pas un la balle au
centre la réalité c'est que toutes
celles et ceux qui sont experts du sujet
disent la même chose et disent que de
toute façon cette réforme ne pèse que
sur les populations qui sont les plus
fragiles et c'est pas difficile à
comprendre vous et moi qui avons qui
sont morts sur le marché du travail
tardivement et bien nous ne sommes pas
touchés par la réforme de toute façon
vous partirez jamais à 60 ans 61 62 ans
vous serez de toute façon amener à
partir plus tard après 64 ans Olivier
c'est le parti socialiste
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes
pas en grande partie responsable du fait
que beaucoup de Français ne pourront pas
de toute façon partir avant 64 moi je
comprends parfaitement le fait que moi
je ne pas être à 64 ou 65 je suis avec
une vie parfois pénible certainement va
y revenir mais enfin ça n'a rien à voir
avec celui qui est au marteau-piqueur ou
qui est sur un chantier ou qui travaille
au 3 8 etc ça n'a rien à voir
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé elle
est très différente selon cadre ou
ouvrier vous avez 13 ans d'espérance
d'un écart d'espérance de vie entre les
5% les plus pauvres et les plus riches
vous avez 8 ans d'espérance de vie de
différence entre le cadre et l'ouvrier
quand même ça veut dire que là on va on
va faire maintenir au travail des gens
qui ont une espérance de vie plus courte
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont avoir une
retraite qui va être de plus en plus
resserré et finalement c'est eux qui
vont faire quoi ils vont payer la tête
de ceux qui ont une espérance de vie la
plus longue et qui est qui ont des
pensions des pensions de retraite qui
sont les plus élevées ça n'a aucun sens
c'est la réforme la plus injuste qu'on
pouvait réaliser et donc évidemment je
m'y oppose fermement et je continuerai à
m'y opposer fermement derrière les
syndicats derrière les millions de
Français de Français qui ont compris
cette réforme n'était pas une réforme
juste ce que vous pensez pouvoir dans le
débat qui s'annonce obtenir des
améliorations voir parvenir à faire
plier le gouvernement qui retire son son
projet ben moi je crois que le
gouvernement serait bien inspiré de le
retirer effectivement et quand on voit
qu'il y a entre 1 et 2 millions de
Français qui est déjà qui sont descendus
dans la rue jeudi dernier ça devrait
être une alerte suffisante pour le
gouvernement comprendre que tous les
sondages les la même chose il y a une
majorité écrasante de Français qui sont
opposés et quand Emmanuel Macron nous
dit qu'il a été réélu sur cette base là
mais c'est tout simplement se moquer du
monde la réalité c'est qu'il a été élu
comment grâce au barrage républicain
d'ailleurs barrage républicain auquel
j'ai moi-même appelé et j'ai voté au
second tour pour Emmanuel Macron non pas
pour son projet mais parce que je ne
voulais pas que l'extrême droite arrive
au pouvoir
il avait d'ailleurs dit entre les deux
tours je considère que ces voix qui
arriveront ne sont pas des voix qui
viennent approuver mon projet mais qui
sont simplement là pour faire barrage
ensuite il y a eu des élections
législatives il n'a même pas obtenu de
majorité qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que les Français sont
précautionneux et qu'ils avaient bien
compris que le pouvoir s'était
jupitérien leur imposerait y compris des
choses qui ne voulaient pas donc il y a
nécessité démocratique de reposer le
débat et si Emmanuel Macron est si
persuadé que les Français l'ont approuvé
sur sa réforme des retraites et bien
qu'il a soumettent à référendum à cette
condition là nous verrons bien ce que
disent les Français et ce sera le jardin
Marine Le Pen a dit hier que les députés
du rassemblement national allaient
déposer une mention référendaire vous la
voterez nous avons déjà annoncé depuis
très longtemps que nous avions une
motion référendaire que nous a que nous
serions voter par l'assemblée que
Marianne Le Pen Marine Le Pen cherche
maintenant à essayer de courir après en
fait les initiatives des autres très
bien ça m'est égal enfin la réalité
c'est que nous avons notre propre
émotion référendaire
un dernier mot là-dessus qu'elle va être
la stratégie du des députés socialistes
et des députés de la nuque hier Alexis
Corbière nous disait qu'ils allaient
renoncer finalement à déposer des
dizaines de milliers d'amendements
qu'elle va être votre stratégie
on a toujours dit la même chose en fait
nous on veut le débat on sait très bien
que de toute façon la réalité c'est que
que l'on vote ou qu'on ne vote pas à
l'Assemblée au bout de 20 jours après le
dépôt du projet donc dans un jour à
partir du dépôt sur le bureau de
l'Assemblée et bien même s'il y a eu un
débat de 5 jours de toute façon ça part
au Sénat vote ou pavotes donc la réalité
c'est que
les amendements en fait c'est quoi c'est
du temps de parole c'est et la
possibilité de débattre plus longtemps
la réalité c'est que de toute façon au
bout de 20 jours c'est terminé donc
l'intérêt de déposer des milliers
d'amendement est très réduit la réalité
c'est qu'ils ont choisi je le répète le
passage en force par une procédure qui
leur permet éventuellement même de ne
pas avoir à prononcer ce mot magique en
tout cas d'invoquer le 4 numéro 3 et
donc c'est vraiment en fait une
entourloupe de l'enfumage complet on va
passer aux parties socialiste alors vous
avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez une
vie parfois un peu pénible j'imagine ça
peut arriver voilà vous faisiez allusion
au dernier événements j'imagine comment
est-ce que vous viviez la situation vous
pouvez nous faire un petit débrief de ce
qui se passe au Parti socialiste en ce
moment bah c'est malheureusement en fait
le Parti socialiste dans ces moins
belles œuvres avec
en fait
inscritin qui s'est déroulé avec un
résultat qui est un résultat clair mais
qui continue à être contesté par celles
et ceux qui l'ont perdu alors même que
il y a eu un résultat d'abord brut puis
ensuite un résultat corrigé en fonction
des contentieux qui étaient nés ne se
scrutin et que c'est
contradicteur souhaite maintenir le flou
pour essayer de créer le vide et c'est
effectivement un supportable parce que
il y a eu un vote militant qu'il faut
respecter et donc maintenant avancer
notamment sur la réforme des retraites
comme on vient de le dire parce que ça
n'est pas acceptable d'avoir finalement
des gens qui disent face je gagne pile
tu perds en fait c'est la réalité c'est
que vous avez entendu une colère aussi
il dénonce les conditions du scrutin il
dit les conditions de scrutin ont été
mauvaises il y a eu des fraudes vous
contestez ça mais il y a eu des éléments
d'irrégularités qui ont été corrigés
c'est-à-dire que dans les sections ou
dans les fédérations où ça peut passer
correctement les voies ont été annulées
et donc on est arrivé à maintenant
extraire en fait les régularités pour
avoir un résultat qui est clair et net
et qui change d'ailleurs assez peu par
rapport aux résultats brut et même si je
devais aller jusqu'au bout de ma pensée
je dirais que si on avait vraiment été
jusqu'au bout de la suppression des
irrégularités je serai même beaucoup
plus haut encore parce que les
contentieux ils existent principalement
dans les fédérations qui ont voté
majoritairement pour Nicolas ma mère
Rossignol donc on en est resté là et
j'ai fait hier j'ai réuni l'ensemble des
protagonistes
Rossignol et moi nous sommes retrouvés
j'ai fait des propositions qui sont des
propositions extrêmement conciliantes
avec tout le monde en disant on va venir
pour rester sur les conditions scrutin
il y a une commission de recollement
vous vous dites elle n'est pas allée
est-ce qu'elle allait jusqu'au bout déjà
parce qu'on a eu on a lu par exemple
David à souligne qui est sénateur et qui
soutien de Nicolas Mayer rossignol qui
dit seul 62 fédérations sur 103 ont été
étudiés la direction actuelle a
interrompu brutalement le travail pour
valider une inilatéralement ce résultat
fabriqué
vous avez d'ailleurs c'est simple nous
avons fait une opération transparence
complète donc tous les journalistes qui
le souhaitent et ils étaient nombreux au
siège du Parti socialiste sont venus
voir eux-mêmes les procès-verbaux des
fédérations donc tout est en fait en
accès libre vous pouvez venir faire vos
comptes vous-même et vous verrez ce
qu'il s'est passé et y compris vous
pourrez regarder quelles sont la nature
des contentieux et ce que nous en avons
fait au fur et à mesure donc ce qui a
été examiné ce sont les ce sont les
fédérations dans lesquelles il y a un
contentieux quand vous avez en fait les
trois mandataires les trois
représentants des textes d'orientation
qui tous valides en fait les votes dans
leur fédération il n'y a pas lieu d'y
revenir on va pas on va pas créer
artificiellement du contentieux continue
à dire que les conditions n'étaient pas
là et continuent à ne pas reconnaître
les résultats de ce scrutin de me
l'explique pas voilà c'est aussi simple
que ça mais ce que je vois c'est que
vous parlez d'avida Souli mais il y en a
d'autres qui avec Nicolas mairie
Rossignol sont dans cette commission de
recollement et qui sont des
professionnels de la déstabilisation qui
l'ont fait congrès après congrès ils
étaient déjà là au fameux congrès de
Reims c'était déjà les mêmes qui
organisaient les choses pour donner le
sentiment d'un immense bazar et empêcher
l'élection de Martine Aubry donc
je vais pas maintenant faire du name
droping c'est simplement et je vous dis
vous les connaissez parfaitement et vous
savez très bien quels sont ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont en fait autour de
nicolas Rossignol et continue à
contester ses résultats donc à un moment
il faut que ça s'arrête il faut qu'on
respecte les militants il faut qu'on
respecte ce parti il faut qu'on fasse en
sorte que on puisse avancer et ne pas
jeter l'eau propre sur l'ensemble d'un
mouvement alors même que nous avons
d'autres sujets à mettre sur la table
dans un moment qui est un moment de
grand mouvement social dans lequel nous
devons nous inscrire parfaitement et
laissez entendre que ce parti-là ne
serait pas un parti démocratique alors
que c'est le parti le plus démocratique
de France et que nous avons enfin je
vous mets au défi de trouver d'autres
parties dans lesquelles en fait les
règles sont aussi rigoureuses on ne vote
que physiquement c'est pendant 5 heures
du 17h à 22h vous faites la journée de
ces cotisations et c'est pas des
cotisations symbolique et vous avez
obligatoirement 6 mois de cotiser enfin
six mois de cotisation enfin six mois
d'adhésion minimum pour pouvoir voter si
bien d'ailleurs que les 2000 nouveaux
militants qui sont venus après l'accord
de la Nupe non pas pu voter franchement
enfin est-ce que vous connaissez
beaucoup d'endroits où on est aussi
rigoureux mais ces règles rigoureuses
très strictes est-ce qu'elles ont
empêché les fraudes ou est-ce que les
travaux la commission recollement
constate qu'il y a eu les fraudes avéré
mais bien sûr c'est ce que je viens de
vous dire il y a eu des endroits où il y
avait en fait des irrégularités
ça empêche pas qu'il y ait eu des
fraudes est-ce que ce serait pas
l'occasion le moment de se dire que
tiens ce serait peut-être bien de passer
au vote électronique ce que font
d'autres parties alors moi-même j'avais
proposé et ça m'avait été refusé ça
depuis quatre ans que je suis premier
secrétaire j'avais proposé votre
électronique et il y avait eu beaucoup
de réticences ça a été adopté alors
c'est long à mettre en place mais par
ailleurs ça n'enlève rien à la
possibilité de fraude parce qu'en fait
quand vous avez des gens qui achètent
des cartes par le biais d'internet et
qui disent pour 20 euros je peux avoir à
5 voix 10 voix 15 voix 30 voix ça
n'enlève rien à l'hypothèse et sans
parler des hackers etc donc il y a pas
de système parfait si vous gardez la
règle des 6 mois à jour de cotisation
même peut-être mais vous allez venir
avec nous travailler parce que moi
j'ai proposé un chantier justement de
réorganisation pour faire évoluer cette
organisation évoluer ses votes évoluer
sa façon de fonctionner donc ce sera
l'un des chantiers de 2023 la question
maintenant c'est comment on en sort rien
vous avez rencontré notamment Nicolas
Mayer rossignol qui n'a pas changé de
discours après votre rencontre comment
le Parti socialiste sort de cette
situation est-ce que vous avez de
nouvelles propositions à faire ce matin
franchement qu'est-ce que je peux faire
de mieux que de dire que nous serons
toutes et tous associés à la décision et
que donc
il y aura un premier secrétaire il a été
élu et puis après il y aura des premiers
secrétaires adjoints et on aura une
forme de collégialité qui permettra de
travailler ensemble voilà ce que j'ai
proposé hier
il veut quatre premiers secrétaires donc
franchement est-ce que vous connaissez
lui qui émerge est-ce que vous
connaissez une collectivité locale où il
y a quatre mers quatre présidents de
région quatre présidents de départements
et ce matin on fait quoi en fait on
invite quatre premiers secrétaires à
venir devant vous pour répondre chacun à
leur tour à vos questions enfin tout ça
n'est pas sérieux il faut quand même
revenir à quelque chose qui ressemble à
une organisation quand même et donc dans
la vie il y a d'abord la reconnaissance
d'un vote et sovate il est clair et
ensuite il y a la volonté que j'affirme
et que je réaffirme ce matin devant vous
l'associer toutes et tous pour éviter
une forme de fracturation et permettre à
chacun de
je te propose en fait d'en être le
garant voilà donc je fais tout pour que
chacun se sente à l'aise et que sur les
sujets qui ont pu nous opposer pendant
le scrutin et bien chacun se dise bah
finalement j'ai aucune raison de voilà
et maintenant si maintenant j'aimerais
comprendre en fait quels sont les
raisons qui motiveraient le fait qu'on
continue à s'opposer et qu'on fracture
artificiellement un parti qui en a pas
besoin c'est ça vous pensez qu'elle
recherche Nicolas meilleur Rossignol et
les gens que ce soit je dis c'est la
conséquence donc je ne sais pas quelle
est sa volonté je dis simplement que une
volonté de vous déstabiliser vous vous
pensez
de Nicolas Mayara rossignol qui serait
très heureux que ce soit le cas voilà
donc
notamment François Hollande lui dit
lorsqu'il y a le contestation il faut
recommencer l'élection
bien sûr en fait vous vous rendez compte
de ce qui se passe il y a des gens qui
disent en fait donc d'abord il faut pas
que je gagne c'est quand même ce que
veut dire François Hollande de la
semaine dernière ce serait fâcheux
disait-il et puis ensuite il y a un
résultat qui nous convient pas et donc
on le comptait sur le contexte sur le
contexte en dépit de toute forme de
réalité et puis derrière en fait à
partir de la contestation on dit il faut
votera combien de fois jusqu'à ce que le
résultat correspondre à ce que souhaite
François Hollande la réalité c'est que
dans un scrutin quand il y a un résultat
et même si c'est 50% en plus une voix on
le respecte et c'est comme ça que la
démocratie fonctionne pour vous mais il
y aura de toute façon un vote dans deux
ans puisque nous avons des congrès enfin
on a je vous rappelle quand même que
nous avons voté il y a à peine un an il
y a un an j'ai été réélu à Villeurbanne
et maintenant un an après on revote
enfin je pense qu'à un moment il
faudrait qu'on arrête de se regarder le
nombril qu'on finisse quand même par
s'occuper des croisades et des Français
et avancer avec eux pour eux parce que
quand même le grand sujet du moment ça
n'est pas l'élection des socialistes le
grand sujet du moment c'est est-ce que
on va avoir oui ou non le recul de l'âge
légal ce sera nous quatre ans et donc on
a besoin des socialistes dans le combat
et non pas dans le combat contre même si
on en a parlé mais est-ce que vous
pensez que des gens comme François
Hollande cherchent à vous affaiblir pour
qu'il y ait scission du parti socialiste
est-ce que vous la redoutez cette
scission
la seule chose que je redoute c'est la
confusion sur la ligne politique il y a
une ligne politique qui a été adoptée
très clairement il y a eu deux votes il
y a eu un premier vote qui était non pas
sur le premier secrétaire mais sur
l'orientation dans cette dans ce vote
80% des socialistes ont refusé la
proposition qui était celle d'Hélène
Geoffroy mais celle de François Hollande
en l'occurrence qui était de dire on
sort de la nuque 80% on dit on ne sort
pas de la nuque donc cette orientation
elle est extrêmement elle est massive
donc maintenant il y a une orientation
il y a eu ensuite un vote sur le premier
secrétaire qui est un vote que je
reconnais serré et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je souhaite associer le plus
grand nombre à la direction et à partir
de là on avance mais il faut quand même
respecter les choses pour fournir cette
idée de d'égalité parfaite enfin quand
même vous imaginez quatre premiers
secrétaires ou trois premiers
secrétaires j'ai fait 49% sur mon
orientation ils ont fait 30 et 20 et
considérez qu'à la fin en fait c'est
logique que vous ayez tout le monde en
fait sur la même marche du podium enfin
là il y a quand même un problème
démocratique il faut quand même que on
se rend compte de ce que l'on fait et
qu'on soit lisible et compréhensible et
surtout je le répète quand il y a une
organisation qui choisit une ligne
politique une orientation il faut en
fait en être le garant et c'est ce que
je serai et est-ce que ce qui comptait
cette ligne ont encore leur place au
Parti socialiste est-ce que François
Hollande a encore sa place aux
participants et je ne suis pas là pour
faire le tri en fait sur la partie
démocratique donc il y a toujours eu
depuis Jules Guesde et Jean Jaurès il y
a toujours eu des gens qui étaient
majoritaires des gens qui étaient
minoritaires j'ai été parfois
minoritaire j'ai été parfois majoritaire
et c'est la démocratie et donc ça
fonctionne comme ça les résultats vous
ne comptez là on est dans un cas où il
comptait le résultat ils conteste la
ligne est-ce que vous leur dites ben la
porte est ouverte
non je ne dis rien du tout en fait
chacun fera selon sa conscience et
simplement quand on est un démocrate et
en général quand on est socialiste on
est d'abord un démocrate et bien on
respecte le fait majoritaire comment ça
va se passer au Congrès du Parti
socialiste à Marseille quel sera
l'ambiance vous allez vous parler un
petit peu ou ça va être à côté non je
parle et d'ailleurs hier on s'est parlé
de manière très civile très courtoise
même je dirais amical en fait il y a des
désaccords mais enfin entre adultes on
dirait de solder des désaccords le
congrès de Marseille il va il va marquer
le le la fin de cette épice se fait cet
épisode fâcheux pour reprendre un terme
que vous avez utilisé tout à l'heure ou
ou ça va être l'occasion d'une d'une
fracture publique
moi je suis
je peux pas vous répondre je ne suis pas
responsable de ce que font les uns et
les autres est-ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que moi je fais tout pour que les
différences s'aplanissent que tout le
monde vous êtes en train de nous dire
que rien n'est réglé pour l'instant je
vous dis que rien il est je n'en sais en
tout cas j'ai fait une proposition
j'attends la réponse de mes amis
on a prévu de se revoir avant qu'on
gagne Marseille et donc c'est vendredi
c'est pas en fait ça dépendra de la dune
de temps de réflexion qu'ils prennent et
des discussions qui peuvent avoir
j'imagine avec leurs amis en fait mais
la réalité c'est que j'ai mis sur la
table des propositions qui ont des
propositions sérieuses qui permettent à
tout le monde de se sentir à l'aise dans
une organisation où tout le monde ne se
sentir bien mais en même temps je le dis
il y a une ligne il y a eu un résultat
sur les votes et donc il faut respecter
et la ligne et le résultat et ensuite
associé tout le monde parce que un grand
parti c'est aussi un parti qui sait se
rassembler pour ensuite rassembler la
gauche et ensuite rassembler les
Françaises et les Français c'est ça
l'objectif et donc maintenant il faut
que chacun prenne la hauteur nécessaire
pour se mettre au niveau des défis qui
sont devant nous enfin c'est pas comme
si on était
49% et qui ne manquait plus qu'un point
pour rester en euphémisme un dernier mot
puisque vous souhaitez rassembler tout
le monde est-ce que les socialistes qui
ont été suspendus suite au législatives
seront réintégrées dans le parti
mais
là aussi je peux pas vous répondre ils
sont dans une vente une commission qui
s'appelle la question des conflits qui
est une commission qui ne dépend pas de
moi et donc je peux vous dire une chose
c'est que les 7 ou 8 qui ont été qui ont
déjà passé par la commission des
conflits ont tous été réintégrés avec
des délais de suspension donc de six
mois à 18 mois et donc il y a eu une
sanction parce que quand on ne respecte
pas la règle et bien c'est normal qu'on
soit sanctionné et je le dis aussi
puisqu'on est à Public Sénat en fait
s'il y avait plus jamais de règles et
que désormais la dissidence était une
une possibilité et qu'elle n'était pas
sanctionnée qu'est-ce qui se passerait
aux élections sénatoriales bien vous
auriez en fait des gens qui sont obligés
de faire la parité sur les listes mais
qui disent finalement puisqu'on devrait
avoir deux élus pour avoir deux hommes
et non pas un homme une femme qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on fait une première liste
avec la femme en seconde et qu'on fait
mise ici dans ta coté et dans ces cas-là
on a deux hommes qui sont au Sénat et la
femme et bien elle restera à la maison
moi je ne le souhaite pas je souhaite
qu'on rappelle qu'il y a une règle et
que la dissidence n'est pas en fait
une voix normale et légitime après
évidemment ça n'empêche pas de
réintégrer des gens à terme parce que il
faut pas mettre à chacun de retrouver en
fait la maison à laquelle il a appartenu
mais ça suppose quand même qu'il y a un
délai je sais pas comment on dit un
délai de réflexion peut-être merci
Olivier fort merci beaucoup d'être venu
nous nous parler ce matin avec ce qui se
passe en ce moment au sein de votre
partie merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation regardez une nouvelle
France rapidement la société reste
encore très sexiste c'est à la Une de
Ouest-France merci Stéphane merci
beaucoup Olivier fort on va